it is very important to take care of
your skin according to this crazy vegas
weather so lead esthetician at the four
season spa is here to get our skin ready
for the next season so first things
first ladies welcome to the show rocky
for having us really appreciate it this
is amy amy i was already admiring her
glowing skin so she's excited to see how
you make it glow even more beautiful
skin doesn't she exactly so
speaking of glowing let's start with
hydration right in vegas personally that
is my issue so let's talk about how to
hydrate your skin from winter into
spring right what you want to do really
is you want to make sure that you use
something appropriate for the skin your
skin type
if you have dry skin you're going to
want to use something that's really
hydrating for the skin if you have more
of a combination skin you may want to
pull back on the hydration and use
something that may be a little bit more
astringent to the skin to help with that
oil production but you don't want to
strip the skin of its natural oils right
and that's why you should see a
professional you know before you try to
diagnose their own skin type so you can
tell people what kind of skin they
actually have absolutely it's important
that you do see an esthetician and they
can
definitely give you some
advice on your skin care for the daily
too absolutely so what what do you want
to demonstrate when it comes to
hydration i have here is i have a
selection of
facial masks that are important
to bring you into spring plump up the
skin anti-age uh so your your skin looks
glowing okay and anti-age with wrinkles
fine lines and aging got it so what i
have here is i have a couple things i'll
just demonstrate a little bit on amy's
arm here um this is a cream mask pre
masks are very very soothing and very
hydrating to the skin you can just see
it i can't feel it but i can just see
the hydration it's so good this mask is
a little bit more refining
it's for more oilier types of skin are
there some berry seeds in there there it
is it's raspberry so this is a natural
type of mask for you it's so nourishing
and then the last one i have is for more
mature skin aging skin skin that may be
uh out in the elements um
and super dry right so it's a little bit
thicker right
so all those components really give you
that that vitamin content that you need
that moisture that you need to help your
skin go through
winter summer and fall okay and moving
on here we have about a minute left so i
want to get to this important part um
you know allergy season it's right under
way we're right it is ramping up you
know people who are dealing with under
eye puffiness what they do well what i
have here for that under eye puffiness
is i have some gold
eye masks
very hydrating for the eyes and i'm
going to just place those on amy
to give her some hydration this is
wonderful for
puffy eyes allergy eyes
tired eyes stand stand back just a
little so people can see all right see
that oh that is so nice how does that
feel amy oh so suzy
and these are things you can buy and
have them at home as well absolutely
yeah
absolutely and it's an easy way to
revive the eye area for that fatigue and
we all work here in this industry so
any little bit helps with hydration
absolutely and sunscreen obviously
number one number one that would be my
number one tip for the viewers is to use
sunscreen it's so important here in
vegas to use sunscreen whether you're
outside inside with bright lights in the
studio under makeup on top of makeup
just wear sunscreen